the gyro can experience one of the
things that I got out of this recent
obsession with American Indian culture
and these stories was realizing how
little I knew about the history of this
country you know you you might know you
might have a basic understanding of what
happened that you learned in school it's
real peripheral you know it's very
surface and then upon reading these
books and made me realize like what
happened here like this what happened
here over the course of a couple hundred
years is almost unprecedented in in
history like that this nation was
conquered by all these invaders that
just kept coming in kept changing the
rules kept breaking trees making
treaties breaking treaties wiping people
out calling things battles when they
were really just massacres of women and
children I mean there's some horrendous
horrendous stories of the justification
of these massacres that were no
different than any other horrific
barbarian slaughter that you might have
heard about in history that's looked
down upon but for years in this country
they were taught as if they were actual
battles I mean the history this country
with in regards to the tribes and
American settlers and the soldiers is
terrifying it's terrifying that this
just happened a couple of hundred years
ago and that people are capable of these
things and that the ancestors of these
people are just roaming around today and
that's what this country was founded on
this country was founded on massacres
right and and and that policy has been
studied by folks like Adolf Hitler and
it was even included he talked about
studying how the u.s. treated American
Indians in his book Mein Kampf really
yes so and but it wasn't just the
battles there have been many different
types of battles that we consider
warfare though it hasn't been done
you know guns and legal right legal
battles exactly I mean since the 1600s
Europeans have been trying to educate us
and assimilate us and civilize us and
have passed laws once the United States
became a new country in the 1800's
passed laws to take our children and
move them far away and and punish them
if they spoke their language cut their
hair put them in the schools that were
military based and they studied
academics in the morning and then they
did trade in the afternoon and in those
trades were to help pay for the schools
so they were basically indentured
servants slave labor making sure that
the school could have enough funds to
pay for their own education and the
boarding school history in the United
States and Canada has horrendous
horrendous stories and the these schools
were funded by the US federal government
and the Association and other groups are
trying to get the United States to
release records of who were the children
in these schools
we think there's a there were about 500
boarding schools across the United
States and about at least 20,000
children that we can figure out were
were killed were died in these schools
yeah so there's the Carlisle some of
this work has been done at the Carlisle
Indian School in in Pennsylvania which
is now owned by the Army Corps Army
Corps of Engineers and there are some
tribes that are trying to repatriate
their children that are in graves there
and bring them back home so this has
been a process all over the country
trying to figure out
you know who these children were where
they belong in and to bring them home
and it's it's been a really difficult
process for the organization to have
them die disease not being fed working
too much all those things that could
kill a child and all these things
there's records of all these different
children and the places they still no we
haven't been able to folks that are
doing this work have not been able to
find all the records and like I said the
federal government probably doesn't have
the records it probably has mismanaged a
lot of the records of regarding these
boarding schools and and there were
different times there have been
different eras of Indian policy where
the federal government was like oh wait
this isn't working let's let's get out
of this business of teaching Indians
let's give it to the churches and let
them do it for a while and then it would
come back in to the federal government
and but the churches would have it and
of course we've heard all of the
horrible things that that different
churches have done to children and there
are still many boarding school survivors
today that can tell those stories of
abuse sexual and physical and who still
live with that today there's a
organization called the Native American
boarding school healing coalition that
is really working on these kind of
issues and have are pulling together the
stories and are also working with
survivors to try to heal from that that
trauma that's not just theirs but it's
it's this intergenerational historic
trauma that has been with our
communities for a couple hundred years
now so there there are a lot of stories
like that and this again this is US
federal policy you know they would while
they were while the u.s. was building
the reservation system and and putting
tribes
[Music]
these blockades if you did not send your
child to school you weren't given
rations you weren't given your food if
you practiced your culture you you could
be killed for practicing your culture
using your language because and because
this was the assimilation policy of the
day and this happened I would say 1850
1870s through the 1920s there was this
horrific period of federal Indian policy
of doing trying to do away with language
communal type living cultural practices
and religion so this isn't just you know
gun warfare this has been a continuing
policy that even affects us today
so it was gun warfare until they got the
Indians to move into the reservation and
then it was basically an annihilation of
the culture right and it meets all the
definitions of genocide from the from
international law
[Applause]